this was once a leafy beachside suburb
fires ripped apart this community on the
new south wales south coast destroying
most houses hundreds of bush fires are
burning across parts of the country
worsened by severe droughts and intense
heat but after weeks of bad news
finally the much-needed arrival of
cooler temperatures and even a bit of
rain quite cool it's in the low 20s and
humidity we've actually had some rain
today thank goodness I don't think I've
ever seen rain for a while so that's
helped the fire situation immensely it's
still not out there so I don't want
people to get complacent crews are
making the most of this brief window of
cooler conditions to bring more fires
under control but across many parts of
Australia fires are burning at emergency
levels and this brief spell of rain
isn't enough to stop it
before the heat inevitably returns
thousands of volunteer firefighters are
in the field protecting communities
around affected states the winds are you
know very very lot less than yesterday
temperatures are cool and these are
great conditions to try and get to time
lines in thousands of people are still
without power with no indication of when
it will return for those on the front
lines Australia's longest bushfire
emergency is taking its toll this
volunteer firefighter was defending the
houses of others when his prized vintage
van was raised by flames he had spent 10
years collecting the parts to put it
together a cool fire really I don't know
I wasn't here yeah it's gone it's the
same ages Lee call hammer is 54 and
treasured possessions family homes but
worst of all dozens of lives this
bushfire season has already taken so
much from so many Australians and
they're still likely to be weeks of
devastation to car
Jessica Washington al-jazeera Batemans
Bay Australia